well for years james craig was the chief
of police in detroit michigan how'd you
like that job
tough gig but he rose to the job
he brought clarity and competence he
served that city
now he has left the detroit police
department has a major announcement to
make he said he would make it on this
show
james craig joins us right now to do
that chief thanks so much for coming on
what's next for you
you know i got to tell you tucker won't
let me thank you for allowing me to come
on your show tonight
but i said i would make the announcement
on your show and i'm gonna do it tonight
we launched today the chief james craig
for governor exploratory committee oh
yes
today and so i'm asking your viewers to
go to
chief jamescraig.com you know tucker
we've talked many times and i certainly
appreciate the opportunity
i've protected and served for 44 years
in this profession the best part the
last eight years here in detroit we know
what happened last year
you know when other cities were burning
we know that
portland seattle los angeles chicago
but detroit did not burn amen
and you know i got to tell you i'm
running
because when i look at what some
politicians are doing across our country
you know let's talk about governor
whitmore she follows different rules
she just does and then i can't help but
think about the small businesses
who are suffering through the pandemic
and now
you know we want to give them handouts
and businesses can't even hire employees
here's the deal folks want a hand up
and i'm all for a hand up but they don't
want a government handout
you know what i'm going to hold our
governor accountable
i'm going to show the governor what
leadership looks like
so again i want your viewers to go to
chief jamescraig.com because
we're part of a movement we're going to
take the state
back boy it needs it so badly i i don't
think i've ever seen a whinier
less competent victim
then than your current governor and i
have to say
i mean we don't endure i'm not endorsing
him but i just when the crisis
came you rose to it and your city didn't
burn and for years people made fun of
detroit oh detroit
but when it came down to it yes you kept
it safe
and i think that i think that really
matters are you ready for what they're
gonna throw at you
oh they're throwing at me now tucker
they know i'm on your show tonight
they're throwing at me tonight this is
about leadership you can't take that
away from me
bring it and let's fight i'm a fighter
i'm a fighter
wait till they call you a white
supremacist
it's coming
[Laughter]
bring it bring it full i'm ready for it
44 years i'm ready i i appreciate it and
i'm glad you're in the race thanks so
much for announcing on the show tonight
it's great to see you
hey thank you so much good to see you
tucker i hope you saved that state poi
does it need it hey sean hannity here
hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else